[Music]  between the snow-covered mountains deep  in kangwon province in south korea sits  one of the country's hottest spa crazes  and we mean literally hotel  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  charcoal played an important role in  korean culture  its use dates back over 2600 years to  heat homes cook food and ward off bad  energy  sojong won and his father make charcoal  from oakwood that is unique to this  region  it's an arduous process that starts and  ends with kilns or giant ovens  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  the kilns function as a traditional  korean sauna a treatment that has been  happening for hundreds of years  customers pay a small fee to spend time  sweating out their toxins in the hot  rooms  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  goodbye  [Music]  you